>> SENATOR, SENATOR, WE'RE JUST
GOING TO -- WE'RE JUST GOING TO
BREAK IN AND LISTEN TO THE
PRESIDENT FOR A SECOND.
>> A CALL SAYING THAT IT'S BEEN
ANNOUNCED THAT IT IS A REAL
DRAFT, BUT IT DOESN'T REPRESENT
WHO'S GOING TO VOTE FOR IT YET.
I HOPE THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
VOTES FOR IT.
THAT'S THE MAIN REASON WHY I
WORKED SO HARD TO KEEP ROBERT
BORUK OFF THE COURT, IT REFLECTS
HIS VIEW ALMOST -- ANYWAY.
LOOK, THE IDEA THAT CONCERNS ME
A GREAT DEAL THAT WE'RE GOING TO
AFTER 50 YEARS DECIDE A WOMAN
DOES NOT HAVE A RIGHT TO CHOOSE
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF SUPREME
COURT DECISION.
BUT EVEN MORE EQUALLY PROFOUND
IS THE RATIONALE USED, AND IT
WOULD MEAN THAT EVERY OTHER
DECISION MADE IN THE NOTION OF
PRIVACY IS THROWN INTO QUESTION.
I REALIZE THIS GOES BACK A LONG
WAY, BUT ONE OF THE DEBATES I
HAD WITH ROBERT BORUK WHETHER ON
GRISWOLD VERSUS CONNECTICUT
SHOULD STAND AS LAW.
THE STATE OF CONNECTICUT SAID
THAT THE PRIVACY OF YOUR
BEDROOM, A HUSBAND AND WIFE
COULD NOT CHOOSE TO USE
CONTRACEPTION.
THE USE OF CONTRACEPTION IS A
VIOLATION OF LAW.
IF THE RATIONALE WERE TO BE
SUSTAINED, A WHOLE RANGE OF
RIGHTS ARE IN QUESTION.
A WHOLE RANGE OF RIGHTS.
AND THE IDEA WE'RE LETTING THE
STATES MAKE THEIR DECISION WOULD
BE A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN WHAT
WE'VE DONE.
SO IT GOES FAR BEYOND, IN MY
VIEW, IF IT BECOMES A LAW AND IF
WHAT IS WRITTEN IS WHAT REMAINS,
IT GOES FAR BEYOND THE CONCERN
OF WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
IT GOES TO OTHER BASIC RIGHTS,
THE RIGHT TO MARRY, THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE A WHOLE RANGE OF
THINGS BECAUSE ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT THIS COURT AND MANY MEMBERS
OF THE COURT, OR A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS OF THE COURT HAVE NOT
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THERE IS A
RIGHT TO PRIVACY IN OUR
CONSTITUTION.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THERE IS.
I THINK THE DECISION IN GRISWOLD
WAS CORRECT IN OVERRULING.
I THINK THE DECISION IN ROE WAS
CORRECT BECAUSE THERE'S A RIGHT
TO PRIVACY.
THERE CAN BE LIMITATIONS ON IT,
BUT IT CANNOT BE DENIED.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THIS HAS
IRREPARABLY -- THE COURT?
WE'VE NEVER SEEN THIS HAPPEN
BEFORE.
>> IF THIS DECISION HOLDS, IT'S
REALLY QUITE A RADICAL DECISION.
AND AGAIN, YOUNG THE UNDERLYING
PREMISE, I'VE NOT HAD A CHANCE
TO THOROUGHLY READ THE DECISION.
IT BASICALLY SAYS ALL THE
DECISIONS RELATING TO YOUR
PRIVATE LIFE, WHO YOU MARRY,
WHETHER OR NOT YOU DECIDE TO
CONCEIVE A CHILD OR NOT, WHETHER
OR NOT YOU CAN HAVE A ABORTION,
A RANGE OF OTHER DECISIONS, HOW
YOU RAISE YOUR CHILD.
WHAT DOES THIS DO AND DOES THIS
MEAN THAT IN FLORIDA THEY CAN
DECIDE THEY'RE GOING TO PASS A
LAW SAYING THAT SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE IS NOT PERMISSIBLE?
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW IN FLORIDA?
SO IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN
AMERICAN JURISPRUDENCE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DO AWAY WITH
THE FILIBUSTER TO CODIFY ROE?
>> I'M NOT PREPARED TO MAKE
THOSE JUDGMENTS NOW ABOUT, BUT
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
CODIFICATION OF ROE MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE.
LOOK, THINK WHAT ROE SAYS.
ROE SAYS WHAT ALL BASIC
MAINSTREAM RELIGIONS HAVE
HISTORICALLY CONCLUDED, THAT THE
EXISTENCE OF A HUMAN LIFE AND
BEING IS A QUESTION, IS IT AT
THE MOMENT OF CONCEPTION?
IS IT SIX MONTHS?
IS IT SIX WEEKS?
IS IT QUICKENING LIKE AQUINUS
ARGUED?
THE IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE A JUDGMENT THAT IS GOING TO
SAY THAT NO ONE CAN MAKE THE
JUDGMENT TO ABORT A CHILD BASED
ON A DECISION BY THE SUPREME
COURT I THINK GOES WAY
OVERBOARD.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> THE MIDTERMS, WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN FOR THE DEMOCRATS' ARGUMENT
IN THE MIDTERMS?
>> I HAVEN'T THOUGHT THAT
THROUGH YET.
>> DO CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE TO
THE COURT IN LIGHT OF THIS, IF
THIS DECISION HOLDS?
>> I BEG YOUR PARDON.
>> DO CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE TO
THE COURT IN LIGHT OF THIS?
>> WE JUST HAVE TO CHOOSE
--
LOOK, THEY REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE'S A NINTH AMENDMENT.
THEY REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THERE'S A RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
THERE'S SO MANY FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS THAT ARE AFFECTED BY